Our next case,
Bernstein versus Niemeyer involves the
lawsuit that emerged from a complicated
investment arrangement in 1983 Niemeyer
and several others formed the CMC
southwest limited partnership in order
to purchase and renovate two apartment
complexes in Houston,
Texas.
In 1984 they persuaded Bernstein and
other plaintiffs to invest $1,050,000 in
the partnership.
In part because the defendants made
a negative cash flow guarantee.
Niemeyer and the Cheshire management
company agreed to lend money to the
partnership each year as part of this
negative cashflow guarantee to cover for
any loss.
That is they would lend any amount by
which the operating costs exceeded income
from rent.
The loans would be repaid from future
years' income or from the gains realized
when the buildings were sold and Niemeyer
and the guarantors claims were to be
paid on the negative guarantee loans
before any claims of bursting or the other
investors,
instead of gaining value as
the partnership had hope,
the apartment complexes in fact
declined in value along with the rest of
Houston's real estate.
As you can see in this graph.
By late 1985 the defendants had made
loans of $3 million under their negative
cashflow guarantee.
They stopped pain in an effort
to renegotiate the mortgage,
but the property ended up in foreclosure
and the whole partnership lost its
entire investment.
Bernstein and other limited partners
then sued the general partners for
rescission of the contract and
restitution of their investment.
The trial court ruled for the defendants
finding that the defendant's breach was
not material in that quote,
the plaintiff's losses resulted from a
bad market rather than the defendant's
breach.
We are reading the decision on appeal
at the Supreme Court of Connecticut
written by Chief Justice Ellen Peters.
Justice Peters used to teach contracts
at yell and I often look up at her
portrait when I'm teaching.
She found that the defendant's breach
was material. The defendant's breach.
Their promise to keep a lending money
to cover any negative cash flows,
not lending money that you promise
to lend is pretty material.
So Justice Peters went on to look
at whether the plaintiffs could get
restitution.
The question was can a plaintiff obtain
restitution when the breaching defendant
got no benefit from the contract?
First,
let's review the different measures
of the plaintiffs possible recovery.
We have mostly been concerned in this
course with damages add reliance damages
as you'll recall from
Sullivan versus O'Connor.
Expectation damages seek to
put the non breaching party,
usually the plaintiff in as good a
position as he or she would be in if the
other party hadn't breached.
In this case the defendants would have
kept making negative cashflow loans,
but remember the loans had to be paid off
before the plaintiff's Scott, anything.
The underlying property was going to
decline in value either way and so the
plane is probably wouldn't have benefited
from the defendant's pouring good
money after bad.
In other words,
expectation damages would be zero or at
least very small because the plaintiffs
couldn't expect to be to receive any of
the money back if the defendant's kept
making first priority loans.
Reliance damages on the other hand
tried to put the plaintiff in as good a
position as she would have been in
had the contract never been made here.
That would mean that Bernstein would
get the whole original investment, uh,
uh, the plaintiffs would get back
their billion dollar and $50,000.
Both of these calculations for damages
take the situation or the position of the
plaintiff as their focus,
but the plaintiffs didn't choose to go
for either of these because plaintiffs
are usually limited to the lesser
of reliance and expectation damages.
More specifically if a plaintiff elects
to pursue reliance damages courts or
will reduce them to the expectation about
if the defendant's persuade the court
that expectation damages would be smaller.
Instead,
the plaintiff in this case sued for
restitution for which the calculation of
damages focuses on the defendant,
the defendant's position or situation.
The goal of restitution damages is to
prevent the defendants from being unjustly
enriched by their breach of contract.
That is restitution tries to put the
party in breach back in the position he
would have been in if the
contract had not been made.
The damages take back the benefit that
preaching party got from being in the
contract.
Section three 71 of the second
restatement sets out to different ways of
calculating restitution damages.
The first and subsection a says that a
plaintiff can get the fair market value
of whatever goods or services
she gave the defendant.
The second calculation in subsection
B says the plaintiff can get whatever
increase in value to the defendant
of those goods or services.
In analyzing this case,
chief justice Peters first looked at
whether the plaintiffs had done what they
needed to do in order to earn restitution.
It is quote,
a condition of rescission and restitution
that the plaintiff offer as nearly as
possible to place the other party in
the same situation that existed prior to
the execution of the contract and quote,
before you can sue for restitution,
you must have already given back
anything you got from the contract here.
There was no evidence that Bernstein
and his fellow plaintiffs had done so in
part because their shares in the
partnership are already worthless when the
breach occurred.
And so giving back their partnership
interest would have been meaningless,
but it's even more problematic for the
plaintiff's claim that there doesn't seem
to have been unjust enrichment.
Instead of the defendant's suffered a
great loss of their own about $3 million.
Even if each additional investor conferred
a marginal benefit to the defendant's
putting the defendant's back in their ex
ante position would require giving them,
giving them money,
not taking it away from the defendants.
Restitution isn't really meant for so
called losing contracts like this one
where all the parties ended up worse
off so nobody has the has gains here for
restitution to claw back.
Stepping back,
we can see how this decision helps teach
us about the shifting burdens in the
election of remedies at common law,
the plaintiff initially gets to choose
among any of the three classic measures
for damages,
expectation,
reliance or restitution and the plaintiff
has the burden of proving the amount
of the elected damage measure.
If the plaintiff chooses reliance or
restitution and meets her burden approving
these damages,
the burden then shifts to the defendant
to show that expectation damages would
be smaller.
A defendant who shows that expectation
damages would be smaller than reliance
is.
It is a is.
It's fairly well established that that
defendant will be able to reduce the
damages down to the expectation amount.
This case shows a similar effect with
regard to restitution because the same
losses that reduced the expectation
measures effectively down to zero are the
same. The losses that reduced
the restitution measure.
But you should also know that restitution
is decidedly more of an equitable
remedy and many courts are much less
clear than justice Peters in deciding what
justice requires.
So here's the quiz.
A homeowner hires a Gardner to landscape
her front and back yards for $25,000
the homeowner breaches when the Gardiner
is finished with the front yard,
assume it costs the
gardener $8,000 to do that.
The front yard that the market price
for the completed work on the front yard
was $10,000 and it increased the home's
value by $12,000 the whole job would
have costs.
The gardener $16,000 match the dollar
values in the left hand column to the
types of damages that the gardener might
get under these different theories of
damages.
Well,
the $8,000 figure is for reliance damage.
This is how much worse off the Gardiner
is for having entered into the contract.
He already spent $8,000,
uh, in doing the front yard.
The $10,000 figure is for the first type
of restitution from section three 71 a
in which the plaintiff gets back the
market price of the services the defendant
received.
The $12,000 figure is for the second type
of restitution from section three 71 B
in which the plaintiff gets back the
value that those services provided to the
defendant.
Their effect on the property's value here,
this is the increase in value of the home.
Finally,
the $17,000 figure is
for expectation damages.
This is the full $25,000.
The homeowner was supposed to pay the
Gardner minus the $8,000 that the gardener
Sade by not landscaping the backyard.
We have seen that restitution damages
seek to take back the unjust enrichment of
the defendants by putting them back in
the position they were in before they
entered the contract.
It does this by forcing them to pay back
the value of what they received from
the contract. Unfortunately, in
situations like the one in Bernstein,
this means that we're defendants
lost money due to the contract.
Plaintiffs cannot recover any restitution.